i'll have to begin by announcing the uh  tragic news that the  um the quit this has been announced that  the queen has done  um  so there's the protocol for this is that  the meeting will now be suspended we  won't continue with this  we'll reconvene tomorrow to  organize the time for the next meeting  and um  it would be great if you could all stand  up  bow our heads for an assignment and  respect thank you  thank you  um  let's say the protocol now is must  apologize to the people who have  attended this meeting  all business is now suspended we'll be  in touch with the the date of the the  reconvening and so i'll now bring this  meeting to a close thank you thanks